[Music]
creativity is you know that feeling of
creating something
making something that didn't exist a
moment before
or at least manipulating something
perhaps that you've known or you've
learned into something new
if you feel a spark of something and you
feel
inspired and you feel like you have you
can't sleep until you get something
on the page or is it something recorded
and then to be able to take
that type of energy and put it into
a little slice of life that we see on
the screen
is exciting
[Music]
it's not always essential that you have
music in a movie i've certainly seen
movies that
use less music or more but it's really
all in the interest of storytelling
and i think that music can really
influence the way you feel about
what's happening on the screen it can
certainly
move you to tears it can scare you or it
can just
be telling a story without you really
being aware of it and when i start
working on scenes i'll watch them like
five or six times before i try to write
music
you know because i'm trying to get
inside the floor of the film
and take that scene
and put it inside the overall arc of the
story and keep it in context in my mind
while i'm writing
i think you know with this particular
film with minari i started writing
the music at the script stage right i'd
read isaac's script
and fall in love with it and absorbed it
and
connected with it and then i just
started to write a bunch of music in the
spirit of it
spike put together the film you know
that scene where they find the goal i
think as a masterpiece just in
storytelling the way he does it you know
the way the film
looked was inspiring all of those things
and inspire me they make you want to be
a part of it
when you see it you go man it's like i
get energized it's like okay let's go
let's go let's go i'm ready let me have
it and then when i have it
here in my studio i'm like all right
everybody get out just
just leave me alone with the with the
film i think it was a quieter
western than than most people would have
imagined
i think a great score goes in and out of
basically being in the front of your
thinking or your perception
certainly it seems to be music driven in
other parts of the movie it can be
quietly working on you
and you're not aware of it film music is
so wide open it can be anything the only
qualifications is that it's music in a
film you know
so film music music film
music has changed clearly you know every
generation the music
completely changes you know my wife and
my kids they call me a nerd i don't care
i'll take it
you know because when i'm not working on
a film
i'm learning i'm trying to figure out
how does this plug-in work how does this
synth work how do i manipulate it to do
what i needed to do
look it's just a matter of constantly
trying to up your game i see electronic
music and electronic scores as part of
the
essential palette now that every
composer needs to be able to
work with you know that's that's just
the way that's progress but i do hope
that
foundationally speaking orchestral music
stays part of the conversation whether
you're using an orchestra or a
synthesizer
or a guitar or a piano you know whatever
it may be
the emotional connection and the
spiritual connection with the film to
the music
that's that that will transcend
everything else
you